moi c'est la première année en 12 ans
que je vois un tel assèchement comme ça
quoi je crois que c'était en 2013 il y a
une grosse canicule on avait passé quand
les sécheresses et pénurideau ou même
les méga bassines sont évoqués on parle
beaucoup des nappes phréatiques et moi
je me suis toujours demandé à quoi ça
ressemblait les nappes phréatiques du
coup je vous emmène avec moi à 150
mètres sous terre dans la grotte de
Clamouse
cette colonne à 300000 ans d'histoire
300000 en histoire climatiques et
géologiques toutes les petites
stalactites et pas et qui au plafond
normalement goûte régulièrement sur
cette zone là moi ça fait 12 ans que je
travaille ici qu'est-ce que tu as
constaté en 12 ans pas mal de choses
notamment en 12 ans le niveau de la
rivière souterraine qui descendait de
plus en plus on peut établer sur 5
mètres à peu près par an le constat
outre ça va être donc la sèchement ça va
être le risque de fissures de failles
d'effondrement de certaines endroits de
la grotte donc là on va passer par la
chatière
ça c'est la deuxième et après celle-ci
on aura trois autres
donc l'idée c'est que tu t'assois tu
mets tes jambes en avant et tes jambes
ça te sert de radar donc au fur et à
mesure que tu t'avances tes jambes elles
vont se bloquer ou pas et toi de
chercher des appuis il est déjà en âge
je précise ça se voit pas mais
donc là ça va être une nouvelle phase un
peu chaotique
on va repasser un deuxième siphon donc
les siphon c'est très très dangereux
donc tu vois là la plage de sable
avant on faisait des petites
explorations par là pour essayer de
descendre plus bas
mais comme les rivières souterraines
montent plus elle brasse plus
régulièrement c'est hyper mouvant donc
hyper instable et c'est genre du truc où
tu peux tu peux marcher à trois quatre
et puis tout d'un coup tu as le sable
qui va glisser et tu sais pas où tu te
retrouves
et c'était comment ça
on vient de marcher à peu près 1h30
j'avais pas mal sué est-ce que vous
voyez derrière moi c'est la surface de
la nappe phréatique
tiens on a perdu plus d'un mètre
le premier constat c'est qu'elle a
énormément baissé en moins de trois
semaines parce que c'était la dernière
fois où on est descendu et du coup on
avait mis cette cordelette au niveau de
l'eau et là actuellement bah l'eau elle
se trouve même pas la toucher elle est
un peu près 1m en dessous ça raconte que
la ressource en eau est en train de bien
baisser et qu'on risque d'avoir pas mal
d'impact du coup si on a le territoire
derrière au niveau des usages de l'eau
et au niveau écologie environnement etc
celle-ci elle alimente ses villages sont
un peu plus de 5000 personnes faut
savoir qu'en France des nappes
phréatiques il y en a des milliers on
les connaît pas toutes on peut pas
toutes les voir
elle est pas potable là comme ça tout de
suite on vient pas se servir avec un
verre d'eau à l'intérieur et après
remonte en surface parce qu'on appelle
le cycle de l'eau domestique donc petit
cycle de l'eau domestique qui est donc
un système de pompage on va récupérer
l'eau on la fait remonter en surface on
la traite on la rend potable ensuite on
l'envoie soit dans un château d'eau pour
la stocker soit directement dans les
canalisations dès qu'il y en a un besoin
dans la ville
de nappes phréatique est représente deux
tiers de notre consommation en eau
potable et c'est un tiers de l'eau
utilisée par le secteur agricole
concrètement ce qui a derrière nous là
ce vide c'est quoi l'impact là-haut
l'exploration va la pousser très très
loin d'un point de vue négatif
mais il y aura plus d'eau dans plusieurs
communes ce qui se passe c'est qu'on a
eu un mois de février et mars quasiment
sec nous ici on a des taux de
pluviométrie extrêmement faible qui sont
tombés du coup cette zone c'est pas
infiltré et là à partir de maintenant
toute l'eau qui va tomber l'eau depuis
qu'on va avoir ne sert plus alimenter
les nappes elle sert principalement à la
végétation qui est en train de reprendre
on est sur le printemps donc le
renouveau végétal et du coup c'est de
l'eau qui ne s'infiltre plus dans les
sous-sols
et d'après les derniers chiffres qui
sont sortis notamment les chiffres du
BRGM on est sur un pourcentage de 75%
des nappes qui ont un niveau faible à
très faible actuellement en France
ça veut dire que les terres risquent
d'être très compliqué et on sait déjà
les conséquences qu'il y a eu sur l'été
dernier on a tous pu observer un peu
près partout en France sur les autres
surfaces donc on peut à peu près estimer
la continuité qui va y avoir il faudrait
qu'on ait vraiment un mois de mai très
très vieux pour que ça puisse un tout
petit peu rattraper la situation et
c'est pas ce qui est prévu
[Musique]
ça y est je suis sorti de la grotte si
vous voulez en savoir plus sur l'état
des nappes phréatiques en France ou à
côté de chez vous vous pouvez suivre sur
les réseaux le BRGM il publie 10
bulletins par